parents would bring them right back
because they've been customers for so
many years and these are very like
fortunate events and I understand it's
like well lucky for you you're right
lucky for me it did happen that way but
when I look at this situation I get sad
because it's like [ __ ] this guy who is a
uh an only father the Mom's not around
and now he's not around for his daughter
too I'm not there's no judgment on what
he did I don't know what he's been going
through how many times he got sick of
getting [ __ ] robbed but I wish he was
still alive to tell the story yeah you
know for sure in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast we
are back in the old Studio once again
only because the studio that I have with
Studio 71 they don't shoot at night and
sometimes I just be doing my best
thoughts at night dude hey man we're
nocturnal people yeah we really are yeah
we for sure are doing that [ __ ] in the
morning was a little difficult and we
still are it's just the the studio was
booked up and I got to go to Hawaii
because our store is opening and
hopefully in about a couple of weeks or
so we don't actually know the uh soft
opening or grand opening date pending
but if you guys don't know I've been
working on opening the store with my
buddy Joe uh in Hawaii right now and it
has been a [ __ ] Journey
almost there if I put any more money in
that store I'm gonna be sucking dick
crazy dick anybody's dick this close to
do it
my [ __ ] dick sucking number is so low
right now it's like 10 bucks
we got the two EDS here today so it's
been a while we got edric and Ed Park uh
for those of you out there who got the
genius brain secret society clubs I
actually had the [ __ ] ups on right now
because I don't deserve the real [ __ ]
but uh they're coming out to you guys
real soon
um maybe this well this podcast is
actually coming out this Sunday so it'll
be out in about a week so we'll be
sending those out real quick
one to two weeks tops yeah yeah I mean I
think we'll be able to start shipping on
in the week of like the fit what day is
it today
seven so like the week of the 15th I
think yeah let's go and I'm telling you
look at this [ __ ] it looks better in
person than it actually does so sick
like in photos it's kind of
indescribable and this [ __ ] right here
is my Cody and pride like this is so
[ __ ] amazing Claudia never lose
Korean brain I kind of want this to be a
tattoo I want this as a tattoo as a
poster as a tattoo on my ball sack no
just do it just do it on the tip of your
dick
[Laughter]
with the urethra
exactly that's what I'm saying so the
world has been going to [ __ ] uh we so Ed
the one with the Nike SB shirt Ed and I
did a podcast which I feel like it was a
50 50 split about our opinions about
something that happened out in Las Vegas
with the smoke shop there was a young
man
uh just to reiterate the story uh he
stabbed somebody to the point where he
was paralyzed because the kid was trying
to um steal Vapes or whatever and I'm
oversimplifying it right now and if you
guys want the full story you guys can go
ahead and check that out obviously there
was a back and forth about the things
that I was saying and so also Ed about
kind of like the value of human life
they're like okay well you're defending
the uh the thief
um you don't care about the person who's
a shop owner this is how you kind of
defend your store so they don't [ __ ]
with you again
um listen I understand all this other
stuff I'm not here to defend myself and
I think people do have very valid points
because everybody it's not it's not a
clear black and white situation right
depending on your experiences and what
you guys went through I I see what you
said it's the exact opposite of what I
felt but it's very valid and I pretty
much understand that because most of you
haven't been in that situation and I
think like the scary thought about that
is when you see somebody coming in you
know trying to rob your store they go
it's either my life or theirs
um and that is such a hard thing to kind
of decide at us at a split second moment
exactly I think think I think in
circumstances like that when people are
viewing it from the outside looking in
they are thinking about it from like a
very calm logical State it's not like
that in the moment though when you talk
about life and death situation you might
do things that you might not normally do
and you might think in that moment when
you're thinking about a situation like
that oh I might do this I might you
really have no idea yeah the the biggest
issue that I think me and Ed had with it
and the reason why like I I [ __ ]
hated that story about people calling
him a hero is that he went on Reddit to
the AMA and he was gloating about oh he
did it amen
I didn't know that was the part that I
was like [ __ ] this guy yeah like he
wanted to kill somebody yeah and um for
me I still stand by that [ __ ] there's
somebody who like even if you had to
defend yourself the fact that you're
sitting there telling like literally
glorifying yourself because you nearly
stab somebody to death because you
wanted the love and the attention from a
Reddit crowd blows my [ __ ] mind and
people in that Reddit were calling him
an idiot like what the [ __ ] are you
doing you're a maniac they're like
delete this [ __ ] yeah like you're
incriminating yourself like it took him
a minute to actually take it down yeah
and he was talking about how oh he
stayed calm because he plays like uh PVP
games yeah she wasn't League of Legends
yeah she said because he plays League he
was cool and calm when his his heart
rate went up wow so this is a very
particular situation I think people need
to understand this is one of the biggest
reasons why I was like he was not there
to defend himself he was waiting for a
moment to stab somebody yeah whether it
wasn't self-defense or not or whatever
his motives were very different and it's
very clear because of how he was
praising himself who the [ __ ] Praises
himself after they nearly stab somebody
to death yeah yeah that that's how you
know something's a little often exact
head you know who does the guy who shot
um
uh uh ah the kid in Florida I can't
believe it I'm blanking on his name it
was a huge thing
um the guy who shot him was uh George
Zimmerman oh yeah yeah yeah yeah a long
time ago a long time ago like those
types yeah right a Kyle Rittenhouse Kyle
written now right now like this kid is
of the same ilk yeah like yeah the way
he's reacting to it exactly and so you
know people kind of wanted us to talk
about this thing that happened out in La
which is you know which is our our block
our neighborhood um in the area that we
live in and everybody here in this room
right now uh small business owners are
all of our parents our small business
owners actually your dad was in the
fashion industry we started in the
[ __ ] Fashion District back in the
back in the early 90s man yeah so there
was a big thing that happened out in La
where um Beauty Supply owner also very
close to me my parents are also Beauty
Supply owners
um customer comes in I'm truncating the
story right now um if I get any of this
information wrong write it in the
comments talk about it I'm doing my best
to remember it but long story short
customer comes in tries to steal a wig
this piece of [ __ ] tries to Jet for it
the store owner
goes after her and her friend I believe
and it's that guy and a girl and he gets
stabbed to death yeah which is the exact
fear that people were talking about when
people were going against what we were
saying yeah in the in the other
situation right
um this is pretty nuts and I you know
people are like oh how do you feel about
it now it's like my statement still
stands the same mine too um mine too and
let me just go ahead and and kind of
give you a full background or just kind
of lay a foundation here
um I'm not sympathizing with any [ __ ]
thief yeah you know yeah I am not
sympathizing with any [ __ ] thief
we're not defending the thieves yeah but
like we're not defending criminal rights
or any of that [ __ ] and so
I value my parents life and my life over
product any day for sure and I think
that the idea behind that is is for a
lot of people too and I think we over
symbolize it oversimplify situations on
our side and the other people's side
where they go well you have to stand up
for yourself or it's going to keep
happening and happening again in in
things of thievery whether you chase
somebody or not is going to happen again
and again and again there is a certain
percentage of loss that you have with
products especially in these areas that
you have to account for you do what you
can but you have to value your life
first and I'm Gonna Leave the GoFundMe
for the daughter because she put a
GoFundMe for her father so if you guys
can donate I'll be donating as well
um
she she wrote in the in this uh
paragraph that she first she was a set
with her father which is understandable
right because it was just the product
yeah and then she said that she started
talking to the other store owners and
they're like no he's a hero he was
standing up for us if it was my dad I'm
not talking about her father yeah it's
not in my place I'm talking about if I
was in that situation yeah I'm not
saying I'd be upset at my father but I
wouldn't look at him as a hero I would
say you made a mistake because that
wasn't worth it yeah you know because he
the situation is he ran out the store
after them exactly they were already
gone I think that's the key question
here is is it worth it right yeah that
that's always the thing that people are
gonna have a debate about and I think
you could look at it from both sides if
we were to look at it just
straightforward like what's especially
because we come from small business
backgrounds ourselves right with our
families immigration family we've seen
that over and over again we've dealt
with it
for me for sure it's not worth it when
when the possible
um situation can lead to violence or
even death but then you also have to
look at it from a standpoint of like
when this [ __ ] is happening over and
over again as you get older too one day
you might just kind of snap yeah be like
[ __ ] that that's enough right and it
might cause somebody to do what this man
did do what do Lee did which is run
after I mean [ __ ] man even my family
member who was out in Fashion District
something happened where he was getting
robbed constantly right one day he had
had enough he chased after the dudes he
jumped onto their car because they got
in their cars grabbed onto the top of
the roof was riding and they were
speeding and then they did a hard turn
he flew off and then he landed on his
feet
no he got [ __ ] up though yeah he ended
up in the hospital with with
um you know I mean luckily nothing
life-threatening injuries but yeah with
injuries and he was bedridden for a
while and then you look at that thinking
is it worth it I think a sensible person
would say no it wasn't but again in that
moment maybe you're having a bad day too
right yeah and and you just got sick of
that [ __ ] yeah like [ __ ] you today is
the last time this is gonna happen yeah
I'm gonna stand up that's why there's
like no judgment for sure on this person
who lost his life right
and even if he didn't lose his life like
I think my opinion stands like I would
rather have him live and the the idea
behind this is too and I and I and I do
want people to understand this is that
if you read his daughter's statement she
actually wrote that he stopped people
multiple he had a broken arm fractured
this got beat up this
he stood up for himself multiplying and
it still happened yeah over and over and
over again and this is why I mean that
it's futile your life is way more
important than these products do what
you can to make sure it doesn't happen
whether security card or or whatever
right and also too like I understand too
you guys have like Los Angeles I don't
want to say the PD but the the law
enforcement here has been trash because
there's nothing done to like really
punish people who are [ __ ] breaking a
lot especially when it comes to thievery
look at all these videos these past year
since California I think they had
changed the law right where you can't
chase after thieves if it's under 900 in
product or some [ __ ] so you keep seeing
these videos from like CVS these drug
stores these clothing stores at the mall
people just grab [ __ ] and walk out
because the employees are told not to
chase after them and then you see why
they're told not to because of
situations like what we're talking about
right now right
it's a weird it's a weird thing to think
about right and I think like when people
DM me and they're saying look how stupid
you are all this I'm like listen you
clearly didn't listen to that podcast
yeah and
um
I get it I understand why people feel
that way they listen but they didn't
hear you if that's a good way to say it
you know what I'm saying they didn't
really hear what we were trying to say
in it because
yeah and uh I've I've definitely had the
situation happen with my mom and I
didn't talk about this right
um people are like well it's lucky that
you didn't have to deal with this [ __ ] I
was like no we did but once again so
here's a here's a quick story uh one
time I was away at this point right I
wasn't at the store when I'm at the
store usually [ __ ] like this doesn't
happen I'm big I'm a big [ __ ] dude
I'm loud mouth as [ __ ] and people kind
of I have friends in the area so if
people kind of [ __ ] with my parents you
have a lot of the problems you're gonna
have to deal with
especially at that time when I was
younger you know young kids around
people would back you up
um
there my mom decided to try to stop
somebody who this this lady was [ __ ]
out of her mind she basically said [ __ ]
you to my mom and she started smashing
all the all of our gels in the store all
of our products are smashing them on the
floor and that's all money for us my mom
comes up and then my mom starts you know
trying to push her out but the lady
starts swinging on my mom and she my mom
had like bruises on her chest because
the lady was shocking my mama and
my dad was upset at my mom right and I
at the time was upset at my dad for
being mad at my mom was like dude you
should have your wife's back and he goes
no he goes I'm not saying that I'm not
mad that they did this to our store or
whatever but your mom could have died
because she was trying to protect
forty dollars with the gel yeah like
let her run her Rampage we could have
called the cops we could have figured
something out but at the end of the day
your mom didn't have to get beat up for
this yeah you know and he was like these
are the these are the choices that we
have to make
whether you think that it's going to
happen multiple times over and over
again
the the loss of product here and there
is never going to be worth your mom's
life so you have to think about that
before you go ahead and start running
after people and chasing after people
because I only did it once and it was a
big mistake and I remember too it's kind
of funny now when I think about it this
dude I forgot what the [ __ ] he was doing
but lo and behold try to Jack some [ __ ]
and I grabbed them and I'm young this
guy's huge yeah and I look back I was
like this guy could kill me and I almost
shat my [ __ ] pants my dad was upset
at me he goes why the [ __ ] did you do
that is it worth it like do you feel
like a hero and the thing about it with
my parents too because we've had the
same customers over and over again guess
what when some of these young kids who
stole their guests would bring them back
their parents their parents would bring
them right back because they've been
customers for so many years and these
are very like fortunate events and I
understand it's like well lucky for you
you're right lucky for me it did happen
that way but when I look at this
situation I get sad because it's like
[ __ ] this guy who is a uh an only father
the Mom's not around and now he's not
around for his daughter too I'm not
there's no judgment on what he did I
don't know what he's been going through
how many times he got sick of getting
[ __ ] robbed but I wish he was still
alive to tell the story no um I it's not
like
um we don't see it like because when
you're a small business owner you get I
guess quote unquote networked with other
small business owners in your area
you know my
one of my friends back in Tacoma
Washington
um like I've known her since [ __ ] like
third fourth grade or something and
we went to churches across the street
from each other like two big churches
and um
yeah um a couple years ago
her mom their family they have a store
out in Tacoma and they got robbed
and she got shot you know and I don't
know the full story I can't recall it
completely where um if there was a
struggle and she got like shot or she
got shot straight up and then Rob
but what I know about the story is that
she like ran after her but then didn't
realize she was shot and then I died oh
my God you know when like like
Ronald Reagan he had an assassination to
to I guess he didn't know he got shot or
some [ __ ] you know
like
um yeah like it you can't tell us like
we don't understand
like we we know business owners who have
lost our lives over this kind of [ __ ]
we've been in similar situations like
it's not like by the way this is not
somebody from like my position where I
just watched my parents go to work I
actually ran one of their stores yeah
you sound too I ran that [ __ ] store
also too I helped them like the idea was
my dad thought I was so [ __ ] stupid
she wanted me to run the story because
he's like parents said the same thing to
me yeah you're not gonna be nothing
is your life now pretty much they just
groomed us to be behind the register
funny thing is like my parents actually
told me that it was an assumption my mom
was like well you know you're doing so
bad at school we thought you were dumb
my parents told me not to apply to
college
[Laughter]
art school is rebellion yeah that
reminds me of a situation sorry to
Sidetrack here but like I got pulled out
of class one time counselor called me
um and then I was like the [ __ ] did I do
this time right
sits me down I'm like yeah so what is
this about I think I was like 14 at the
time or something it's like so have you
started thinking about college
I was like uh not really I'm like 14 you
know I guess at some point I will she's
like so so are you thinking about like
universities I was like I guess it's
like no you should start thinking about
Junior College
yeah what the [ __ ] what is this you
pulled me out of class to insult me
verbally right now I swear to God these
counselors don't know [ __ ] sometimes man
like when I was being bullied like
[ __ ] in high school you know all
that racism and all that yeah yeah and
like I was like really just like up to
here about with that [ __ ] so I went to
the school office and then I was like
can I speak the counselor
and then she pulled me into her office
and I sat and I told her all the things
that are happening to me this person
said this everybody calls me that this
happened to me in the hallway whatever
she goes
I'm so sorry that's happening you but
I'm not that kind of counselor
she's uh what's that called like a
guidance guidance counselor to help you
with your college applications she's
like listen here [ __ ] just deal with it
what classes do you want to take that's
so like for me I was like [ __ ] No One's
Gonna help me and then that's where I
was just like [ __ ] it I'm just gonna
have to take care of myself I mean
that's what it always felt like when I
was when I was in elementary school you
get bullied a lot and then I remember I
would always retaliate right so I would
always be in these fights and then like
both of you I was like no one of us is
not wrong here somebody is [ __ ] with
me constantly but see bringing these
things up actually is a good kind of
segue in back into the conversation
right right no for real is is like yeah
you've had enough enough is enough I'm
[ __ ] sick of it I try to be you know
uh patient about it I try to be peaceful
about it but now
you just it just that right moment in
the wrong time where you just have to
act because the people in charge the
Authority or the government or the the
school [ __ ] they're not doing [ __ ] yeah
yeah right and so I got suspended from
the bus for defending myself from some
[ __ ] kid trying to bully me right and
he's I'm Korean and he's younger than me
I'm not gonna [ __ ] allow that [ __ ]
yeah yeah you know I don't care if
you're white or not it's like you're
this little kid and you're trying to
bully me on this bus so I kicked his ass
like literally I threw him on the ground
and he was on his hands and knees and
his butt was right there so I literally
kicked him yeah
and I got suspended from the bus I
couldn't take the bus anymore like I
hated those things and like I said I
understand like you just never know
what's happening in this situations and
what your mind is going through but I
also want to frame it too where I have
also told stories where I've said this
too like when I was a kid I used to get
bullied so much but the bullying stopped
as much because I just made it a problem
for people to bully me because I wasn't
an easy target right so I do you
sympathize with that but I was also
smart about my [ __ ] too like I also told
that story on this podcast where I had
like an older dude put a gun to my dick
I didn't be like I'm not getting bullied
today
that's enough
today yeah I thought he blast my dick
off yeah and I'm like I'm a hero yeah
but in theory I'm still a man yeah we're
not challenging other people to come at
us yeah yeah yes you know for sure
whether we're at school getting bullied
or whether we're running our grocery
store if someone [ __ ] up like I'm not
trying to call other people oh I dare
you to [ __ ] with me I wish you would
[ __ ] with me like I know I wish this
would stop yeah yeah no I think it's
about sensibility right because like
even when my pops had a you know his
business in South Central like there
would be petty theft where kids would
try to steal like bags of chips or
whatever right he would if he sees it he
would stop him and be like hey
give it up right yeah like hey you know
what you did we I saw you or we caught
it on the camera but then during the
riots right we're talking about he knows
his business is about to [ __ ] get
wrecked yeah
he could have decided to go out there
and be like [ __ ] that I'm gonna break
down yeah yeah yeah but he decided not
to be I mean if it was in K-Town maybe
it would have been a different story
because they might there might have been
more support there but you know in South
Central there was nobody to really back
him up the neighbors tried to help but
it got too crazy
I think some people might have gone out
and maybe lost their life over it or got
seriously injured but my pops is like
you know what I gotta take the L on this
if I go out there I could seriously get
hurt or even die is it worth it we're
not talking about a couple you know
forty dollars a couple bags we're
talking about his livelihood yeah what
he worked for if that [ __ ] gets ruined
he's pretty much starting from scratch
again right yeah so you know it's like
time and place but emotions get the best
of people sometimes yeah we're not like
we're not trying to victim blame either
right like what happened happened yeah
I'm not saying oh you should have never
went after them but then it is the truth
like the core of what we're trying to
get to is like what are you in control
of yeah right when people need to take
back control like is it through fear is
it through Force you know or are you
having some foresight and looking into
the value of your own life or do you
want revenge it's kind of trippy too
like I don't you know when we're when we
hear these like stories of tragedy
happen constantly we kind of get so
desensitized to it even for me as a
business owner I hear the story like I'm
not the sensitized to it but the sense
is ties
you know we've how many times can we
keep hearing these [ __ ] stories right
yeah and that nothing nothing is really
being done about it that's why I also
understand why people were angry in
these comments because they're also very
very frustrated even if they haven't
gone through it themselves again we were
talking about how people are this trauma
porn you know they're getting addicted
to reading this trauma so they're
they're feeling as if it's happening to
them right now even though it isn't
right and it sucks it really [ __ ]
sucks that there's really like what are
the options that are people having and
this is why people are writing comments
like oh you empathize with the thieves
versus a family that's that's suffering
and that's a hundred percent not the
[ __ ] case right I just the point that
I want to get across is that I'm always
going to choose my life over
this stuff yeah always because now this
girl is going to I don't know if she's
married now or she will get married she
won't have her father there you know uh
these are the things that are important
to me right because those products can
be replaced and even though I'm not
saying that I'm gonna let somebody just
walk into my store and steal things
right there is going to be a point yeah
I am going to stand up for call the cops
or whatever and try to figure this out
but the city has to do something about
the [ __ ] they can't keep on letting
[ __ ] thieves get away with this stuff
it's it's absolutely stupid it's
becoming like a lawless land it's it's a
huge structural issue within the
government and you know local like city
um and honestly yes the state too
because it's you hear all these stories
happening
North California right North Carolina
Northern count yeah like
a bunch of these stories keep coming out
about [ __ ] that happens in San Francisco
and Oakland and all that [ __ ] with like
the same [ __ ] that happens here in L.A
yeah you know and nothing gets done and
then on top of that there's a homeless
issue on top of that there's like zero
trust in the police well there's
corruption also with an LAPD I think
there was a story recently about an LAPD
officer got killed right he got like
beat up by a bunch of yeah the cops act
like gang members it was like an
initiation yeah what happened yes it's
something like um he the the cop who who
lost his life was I guess not uh I know
kind of repping there yeah
so to speak he wasn't playing along I
guess with what they were doing whatever
it may be and I guess they try to teach
him a lesson about it and he ended up
getting killed wait the cops killed him
yeah yeah like I don't know what the
exact story for the the reasoning why
but yeah there was that [ __ ] up yeah I
mean it's kind of in line with that dude
I think this was in 2012 2013 who's that
guy Chris Carter or some [ __ ] no he's a
football analyst but he was
Tucker yeah do you remember that where
this cop went rogue and started killing
all these people who were corrupt like a
judge or D.A or and all that stuff and
he was going around killing people and
there was a huge Manhunt for him you
know to the point where they like shot
up this Toyota Tacoma full of two
Mexican ladies because they thought it
was him they like shot it with like 60
plus 100 plus bullets and then he was in
a [ __ ] cabin in Big Bear or some [ __ ]
yeah yeah
the LAPD has a line and you better stick
to that line or you're gonna get [ __ ]
up so so the dude the LA PD officer who
was killed accidentally during training
he was investigating other officers who
took part in a gang rape
and he was accidentally killed during
training when he got into a scuffle how
come nobody's I didn't hear about this
[ __ ] yeah dude like there's massive
corruption dude the corruption in lapd's
long-stemming decades you know it's no
mystery but it always just kind of gets
swept under the rug and you know there
are things that we don't [ __ ] know
about in this world like everybody
thinks that they
like the system is supposed to work for
us and it's supposed to be Flawless and
perfect and it's not that way at all and
we're finding this out obviously the
internet has its flaws but the internet
does something too it's like an
information Highway where people things
just can't be denied at a certain point
I just heard the story from a buddy of
mine where look I I lived in Glendale
right and you know if you guys
know about Glendale in this area there's
there's these talks about there being
like Armenian Mafia and a long stem of
it right let me tell you something I
don't know if this is I don't think
that's hearsay this is real right so a
buddy of mine witnessed a [ __ ]
and
listen this is just what he saw right he
doesn't know but he he lives in um uh
Apartments there and he saw this car
collision I'm paraphrasing this I might
be getting some of the details wrong but
car crash happens and it's like this you
know fancy black car this Armenian dude
and a bunch of Armenian guys walk out
this other person
hey bro what the hell bro he starts
fluffing his [ __ ] chest hair yeah
exactly with the plunging v-neck he has
a delicious delicious bowl of [ __ ]
[ __ ] fluffy saffron rice and he's
eating it Armenian [ __ ] Rices
money but anyways he comes out and he
could kind of hear them arguing the
person who got hit by the guy in The
Armenian is [ __ ] screaming at him
yelling at him but he knows like oh this
this might be some [ __ ] up [ __ ] so
cops come by to the scene The Armenian
dude that's all in black or whatever
walks up to uh the cop talks to him
they're laughing shakes his hand
takes his car just drives away from the
scene and the guy is like screaming like
what the [ __ ] he goes cops like I didn't
see what happened so and the guy's like
trying to figure out what the hell's
going on he goes honestly it looks like
it's your fault and he's hearing this
like from you know medicines because he
lives in the apartment next to it yeah
and he's like what the [ __ ] is going on
like how come that guy just got to go in
his car and leave yeah and then the cops
are just saying didn't see what happened
so you know there's [ __ ] that's going on
in this world that we don't really
[ __ ] understand no question about I
don't know who that fluffy chest man is
but he's somebody you know he's somebody
to go ahead and walk up to a cop They're
laughing and spying he tells him to
bounce yeah like nothing is wrong and
this guy who just got his car
obliterated to Pieces Just sitting there
like what the [ __ ] is going on it could
have been off duty officer too you know
maybe yeah could have been undercover
it's like uh there's still secret
societies I mean I mean no pun intended
real secret society yeah in a sense
where like
um whether it be organized crime or even
like you know diet yeah you expose our
secret
podcast anymore people who just are
connected to you know and [ __ ] like uh
what's that [ __ ] you know you wear a
ring or some [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
Freemasons Freemasons or whatever like
that I don't know
I mean this is kind of a segue but talk
about like corrupt cops dude did you
guys watch the Jeffrey Dahmer thing not
yet I mean I I know enough about him
here's the thing like I didn't I know of
Jeffrey Dahmer I know that he's just
crazy serial killer [ __ ] we we
all know about this guy's name right
because it was such a huge thing that
happened yeah and obviously not that
long ago now I didn't know anything
about the details right so I was reading
up on the stuff before I wanted to watch
the show I actually thought the show was
going to be a documentary but it's
actually an episodic Series yeah yeah
couldn't watch it it was too real
because I I read up all the details yeah
and then watching how well they
reenacted it made me feel [ __ ] weird
it creeped me the [ __ ] out because at
first because when I was on Twitter
there was a lot of people saying like
this is disgusting you're just
re-traumatizing the families that went
through this stuff and I didn't
understand because I I know that there's
a lot of documentaries that kind of
already do this yeah but I didn't know
that this wasn't a documentary and how
accurate these actors were and they're
right it was it's heavy it is [ __ ]
heavy I can handle some pretty foul [ __ ]
pretty dark gory like nasty [ __ ] but I
think I'm maybe like four episodes in I
really can't watch more than like even
during one episode I'm thinking halfway
through like dude I might just watch the
rest of this in that time man I watched
the like half of the first episode and
because I read so much of that [ __ ] yeah
I just it was it almost felt wrong for
me to watch this [ __ ] right because
you're being entertained I'm being
entertained by this [ __ ] psychopath
this kind I kill damn near what 20
something people it was or 17 17 people
some [ __ ] uh double digit for sure
double digit for sure enough to be an
Infamous person and he ate some of them
ate their hearts ate their hearts yeah
like the whole backstory of Jeffrey
Dahmer and I'm pretty sure you guys if
you guys haven't watched the show
already I'll give you guys a little
background of him so I I jog at night
right I'm jogging like a mile and a half
too first of all the way this
infomercial video that I that I was
listening to [ __ ] me up a little bit
because in the beginning he goes Jeffrey
Dahmer was a young teen where he tried
to kill a local jogger this neighborhood
but this guy got really lucky
because the one day that Jeffrey Dahmer
was trying to hide he had a baseball bat
or something like that and he was trying
to kill this guy it's the day that he
wasn't there and that was the first time
that he was trying to murder somebody
yeah
um and it's weird how you when we go
back into the topic of this broken
justice system there were so many
[ __ ] times where Jeffrey Dahmer could
have gotten caught right oh yeah dude
especially with that [ __ ] Miner that
Asian kid yeah or I know that story I
never see the show but I always knew
that that's [ __ ] crazy man yeah it's
like and then the the [ __ ] call after
his neighbor follows up hey so you guys
why'd you guys leave he's like ah
there's nothing to worry about he's like
are you sure like that looks like a
child to me he said no no no it's just
it's just some like boyfriend boyfriend
thing he's like no no no but it looks
like a child did you see his ID to make
sure he's in a he's like ma'am don't
worry about it we told you we took care
of so like not only was it reported cops
showed up went into his room to
investigate smells that foul-ass smell
from a [ __ ] body in a vat of acid so
you know so if you guys like if you have
never smelled a decaying body yeah the
only reason I know is because I smelled
like roadkill like there was a dead dog
while I was walking around Long Beach
and there was this dead animal I think
it was a dead dog it was just there it
was always
and it is
I don't know if it's because of
something instinctual in us as human
beings yeah would I smell that [ __ ] I
immediately knew it was a carcass and
I've never smelled one before yeah and
my hairs on my arms raised up and I
wanted to throw I was just gonna say
your hair stands up yeah so there's
something instinctual in us when we
smell this that we know that this is a
unique and weird smell it doesn't it
smells like a dead body and I've never
smelled a dead body before and then
these cops just smelt it like you know
yeah
it's like what's that smell he's like oh
it's just you know pork meat that went
bad yeah it is it is absolutely insane
so this kid the the lay ocean kid who I
believe he was 14 years old yeah
um so Jeffrey Dahmer was doing
experimental [ __ ] where he was trying to
lobotomize people to make sure that
they're zombies so he could [ __ ] them
over and over and over again that they
would never leave him exactly so he was
trying to put uh I believe it was
hydrogen chloride or hydrogen peroxide
in his brain he was doing multiple
different like lobotomy me experiments
yeah and so he was it didn't work
obviously the kid ran away this kid's
outside cops take him bleeding from his
head mind you bleeding from his [ __ ]
head escorts him back
to Jeffrey Dahmer's [ __ ] apartment
yeah was he naked too or something I
think he's like half naked yeah yeah and
the the [ __ ] up thing about this too
is that that cop got interviewed or um
kind of I won't say like debriefed and
he said there was nothing wrong like I
couldn't there was nothing wrong with
the situation for me to feel like
something was wrong
Cole in his [ __ ] spot I mean like I I
don't know if I should say it but this
sounds like Peak white privilege
cause if a black dude yeah oh yeah you
know 14 year old boyfriend blue shirt in
the head I mean well that and it took
place in like a neighborhood or an
apartment complex with a lot of
minorities it was a black woman who
reported it yeah you know so they're
just kind of like he told her like shut
the [ __ ] up yeah it's a Lover's Coral
like stay out of it like the lady was
like trying to plead with the cop like
yo this is [ __ ] up I know there's
something wrong with this guy she goes
she tells him tells her to shut the [ __ ]
up yeah
insane this is why I I think like I
these things like you you don't hear
much about black serial killers
right and it makes me think like this is
just some [ __ ] white people do this
crazy [ __ ] right or is it because black
people are aware of white privilege and
they can't get away with this [ __ ] yeah
it's not that they haven't tried it's
just because of this [ __ ] racist
Society they have to be better serial
killers true that's true I mean he it
was so weird okay I mean we can go into
this whole like psychology of like how
he developed as a serial killer he had a
really [ __ ] up life um [ __ ] up
childhood growing up as a kid her mom
was like on pills and drugs while she
was pregnant yeah her his father was a
scientist and he actually started
getting into like dismembering animals
and bleaching bones because that's what
his father did as a scientist so that
was like his first introduction yeah
um there was points where there was a
story
um where uh he was being interviewed and
he told the story about the first time
that he ever like enacted in like uh a
killing a living thing was when he
brought this tadpole in for show and
tell and then the teacher gave that
tadpole to one of his classmates yeah
pissed him off he go was over to his
friend's house pours gasoline no that in
the show he's still in real life he
actually poured gasoline's tank and
killed the tadpole there was another
part where he killed a dog in the forest
he impaled the [ __ ] dog's head onto a
stake and left it in the forest all
these signs That's The Telltale sign of
like serial killers is it is like people
and childhood like kids who kill animals
yeah so there were all there was a point
where he actually had a dead body in his
car and there was like he already
dismembered it in plastic bags and the
cop pulled him over and he goes oh
what's what's back there he goes dead
bodies they laugh and then he just
drives himself oh my God how [ __ ]
nuts is that [ __ ] dude the the Jeffrey
Dahmer thing blew my [ __ ] mind that's
why I couldn't watch the show I
understand why family members who have
gone through this would be so against
this thing because it creeped me out and
I'm on the periphery right I'm just
watching it for quantical entertainment
it's too real for me to watch I can look
we see some [ __ ] up [ __ ] one of my
favorite movies oh boy yeah right yeah
you know you know the props to the actor
because you know who that guy is it's
the kid he's he's the dude play
quicksilver in X-Men right yeah he looks
exactly like him yeah and apparently
apparently he's also an American Horror
Story too right uh that actor because
he's played like uh
uh who the [ __ ] the Manson family
who's the cult leader uh Charles Charles
Manson he played him uh he played like
all these guys
man he played him too well dude treat me
the [ __ ] yeah out dude so I kept on
listening um to all the stuff and I was
reading more about him all of his
victims are he was gay closeted gay he
went to move him with his grandma
because his parents couldn't really deal
with him and I guess the only person
that had a calming presence on him was
his grandma as a child and then he just
kept dismembering bodies and his grandma
would complain about the smell or
whatever and he would just deflect he
eventually moved out moved into an
apartment uh he actually went into the
military yeah he did he was in the
military and he was [ __ ] drugging and
butt [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of people dude
the [ __ ] yeah so not including the 17
people that he murdered or so or
whatever the double digits of people
that he murdered I don't know how many
people this feel raped yeah all these
people he violated yeah yeah and the
weirdest thing about this guy is that
when people would talk about bottom they
say like he actually bought a lot of
serial killers there's highly sociable
like when you talk to them you can't
really tell they're like the Talk of the
Town it's the same same thing with the
guy who was um the killer clown
Gacy
John Wayne Gacy he was a community
leader yeah right everybody in the town
loved them he dressed up as a clown
doing like Community parties for kids
people [ __ ] love this guy but he had
like 30 some odd dead bodies in his
floorboards in his house there's the
other dude um it's it's like the [ __ ]
three kings here of serial killers who's
that other guy very famous serial killer
um but he would pick up girls all the
time and just kill them and like oh and
[ __ ] their dead bodies
there's Casey there's Dahmer and then
the third one he was the first guy Super
Famous the doctor series
the dude that uh girls liked yeah [ __ ]
what's his name oh yeah we can't
remember it but yeah they all have the
same glasses though yeah
the serial killer starter kit yeah this
guy was a good looking dude I can't
believe I can't remember famous yeah I
can't remember his life um like yeah he
would like hide their dead bodies go
back to the dead bodies like days even
weeks later whether rotting and you get
turned on and like Ted Bundy yeah yeah
he'd [ __ ] their like [ __ ] rotten
bodies yeah you know he'd [ __ ] their
Dead Eye holes and [ __ ] you know like
that kind of this that is so [ __ ]
disturbing man it's like you know I
don't know what it is like was it
just because they could get away with it
in the 70s is it just that much harder
to get away with it now because we're
way worse the first time he ever killed
um what's his face not not John Wayne
Gacy I'm forgetting his [ __ ] name
already
Jeffrey Dahmer Jeffrey he [ __ ]
bludgeoned somebody to death with a
[ __ ] dumbbell this hitchhiker yeah
and he found out that he wasn't gay and
he was he was well I guess I can't
really [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy so he decided
to bludgeon somebody with a dumbbell
dude
insane and there's so many murder and
there's probably more things that he has
done that people can't even account for
even this even though he confessed to
all the stuff the best I guess like the
best but if you guys don't know he
actually died in jail because he was
serving like five or six consent
consecutive life sentences right and
there was another guy who was a murderer
that [ __ ] killed him in the showers
in prison oh really it was a black guy
yeah [ __ ] beat this [ __ ] beat him to
death right and hit when he talked about
him beating him bludgeoning him to death
like um he said that he had no facial
expression no emotion no noise and he
just
took it well the guy is a [ __ ]
psychopath I mean was it because it was
uh he was a child molester kind of guy
I'm pretty sure because he just killed
all black people yeah killed a lot of
black people yeah and it's just a creepy
[ __ ] in general right now during
this time homophobia it was probably
[ __ ] rampant you know racism [ __ ]
rampant so they didn't care about these
people's lives no matter how many times
they reported about it and that was like
the huge thing that was going on there
was protests about it was all over the
news newspapers about how this was a
clear sign of racism how much the
[ __ ] law enforcement was super biased
like they just didn't care about these
marginalized people they did not [ __ ]
care I wasn't there at the time
obviously but I can clearly see that
because that's still an issue today
obviously not to that extent but
how infuriating is that like how [ __ ]
infuriating it took like almost like a
high double-digit amount of these people
to die be like okay
and it took a guy to run out butt naked
and jump on top of a cop car to be like
maybe something's wrong here right right
and and the travesty of it all is that
it could have been stopped multiple
times yeah before it got anywhere near I
mean should any you know even one death
is one too many but yeah it could have
been stopped so many times in the fact
that and most likely because he's white
he was able to get by and get a pass for
even as creepy as that [ __ ]
looks and and talks he was able to still
get a pass dude that when I when I was
uh reading up about uh John Wayne if
like I did this thing where I go into
rabbit holes yeah like John Wayne Gacy I
was like this [ __ ] nut job dude yeah
he it was like the most amount of like
murders or serial killers ever done in
the United States or some [ __ ] like that
yeah and they were all under the
floorboards and this guy had absolutely
no remorse so towards because he
actually got the death sentence but it
took about 15 years for him to get it
because he kept on doing these plea
deals until it ran out and I think um
well his last meal was a bucket of KFC
um and a few other things but before he
passed away I think he said [ __ ] you
or like go to hell yeah so he had
absolutely no remorse he wanted to kill
these people yeah and he killed [ __ ]
everybody I I read a story about his
first murder and it was with a teenage
boy right uh Casey I believe was a
Dahmer [ __ ] I can't remember but I mean
like
he had hooked up with a kid
you know and in the morning
um when he woke up he saw the kid with a
knife in his hand so we went over went
over and beat the [ __ ] out of him and
took the knife and killed him instead of
the kid right and then what he actually
realized was like that kid made
breakfast for him and he had the knife
because he made a pie or some [ __ ] I
don't know and he was trying to come in
the room and say hey I made breakfast
but he saw a knife and just attacked him
and killed him and that's where he was
like I like this [ __ ] like killing
that's that's what awakened his yeah
monster inside of him yeah and this fool
just ate breakfast after you probably
did he finished his food yeah before
even you know dealing with the body he's
probably like well I can't let that go
to waste yeah it's kind of insane like I
didn't realize how many like I never
really wanted to look into serial killer
try because I actually used to listen to
this podcast called sword and bone or
sword and scale so sword of scale is
actually a a s a podcast about serial
killers
um and multiple like crimes and cases
and I used to listen to [ __ ] because my
brother got me into it and it was you
know kind of interesting at first and
the last one that I listened to cut me
off of the podcast forever because it it
I don't know if it made me sad per se
but it [ __ ] [ __ ] with me a little
bit so there was this guy and he was
talking about
[Music]
um
he I'm not if he was a serial killer or
a serial rapist or whatever the [ __ ] he
was right but basically he raped his
daughter
um this daughter and the way he was
talking made me angry and also made me
disgusted so they the person that's
interviewing the serial killer or
whatever after they get caught he was
basically saying he was talking about
what he would do to his daughter and he
was saying that oh yeah so my daughter
um
even if she didn't have to go to the
bathroom I would make her go to the
bathroom and I would watch her pee and I
would never she was not allowed to leave
that room until she had to take a piss
if not I would beat the [ __ ] out of her
and I was like I can't listen to the
[ __ ] man yeah and he would talk about it
as if it was a dumb question being asked
yeah no that means some of those guys
talk about it very matter of fact and
that's another thing to point out why
are they all men too yeah
I don't have you do you know of any
female cereal probably is but they're
all men yeah they don't they don't get
the media attention yeah yeah or maybe
it's not as gruesome or ever as as bad
um they just time it up and nag yeah
because there's there's another famous
uh one of the most famous serial killers
Ed Kemper right who decapitated his mom
and skull [ __ ] her decapitated head
and they asked why did you do it is that
because she used to always nag and I
just wanted her to shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
well you also know about um you know
Patton Oswald's wife who passed away she
was trying to find a serial killer out
of space out of Sacramento my hometown
so this is like back in the day where
Sacramento is a farm town right so
um
it's just a small town everybody knows
everybody and
uh there was a I can't remember the
serial kills name if you know in the
Zodiac Killer oh I think it was a zodiac
because he was killing out in the bay
like Vallejo yeah he's the Zodiac Killer
so he got caught only not that long ago
no no he never got right yeah it's
probably somebody else yeah so well he
got caught right in his old old ass old
age yeah and so my buddy that I know
personally in Sacramento told me he goes
I actually know him I was like how I was
like he was just this he was like I know
his kids because his kids went to my
high school but even their kids knew
that his dad was a little off they just
didn't know what the [ __ ] he why he was
so weird but he was this notorious
[ __ ] serial killer that never got
caught he just got really really old
yeah but his dad was always their dad
was always [ __ ] weird always a little
off but he told me like they knew about
him in the community he was like this
weird dude
but he would go around like murdering
and raping people yeah so one of the
like famous stories that people say is
that he would break into these homes he
would have a gun and he would rape
um the wives of these husbands and he
would place a bunch of plates onto the
husbands as they're laying down and he
goes if I hear those plates [ __ ] move
I'm not only gonna rape your wife I'm
gonna murder her I'm gonna murder you so
they would have to watch their wives get
raped my God
this is [ __ ] nuts this is like a
famous dude like in the Bay Area in the
Sacramento area and I think you know he
only got caught recently
okay and he was just a part of the
nobody [ __ ] knew had a wife had like
a few kids and my friend went to school
with their kids crazy how nuts is that
[ __ ] dude blows my mind that's why we
need state-sponsored the [ __ ]
counseling therapy man like I mean and
that's the thing maybe we're not hearing
like because there were so many of these
serial killers we hear that about them
and they're from the 70s or the you know
80s or some [ __ ]
it seems like something happened like
whether it's the internet like in the
90s but then they just kind of stopped
coming about like as as terrible as as
you're describing right right you know
that [ __ ] like seems to have gone away
but
you know
back to where you know where we are like
uh I had originally talked about the
state of our society today
like
I heard that there was a new serial
killer coming around like in California
God damn it really I forget it feels
comfortable but then it was in the news
though like because we don't hear about
serial killers in modern day yeah yeah
it seems to be a phenomenon of the past
that's true there was no
telecommunications I guess or there
wasn't the amount of law enforcement but
something about the past like made it so
like open for these serial killers to
just do their thing yeah bro I get you
know and I don't know if this is
obviously I haven't seen any statistics
or numbers for this [ __ ] but just us
talking about like how scary is it to be
a [ __ ] woman dude how [ __ ]
scariest [ __ ] I know like even when I
think about Muriel traveling I I get
sometimes I get worried I'm like no I
always tell like listen keep your
[ __ ] wits about you don't be [ __ ]
going to bars and having your drinks
open I don't trust any of these [ __ ]
for sure for sure you have to have your
guards up as a woman just just just to
be careful you know I
it's terrible that women need to have a
system in place when they're going out
on a date like hey I'm gonna be texting
you uh where we're at yeah you know what
I mean like I've never done that as a
dude on a day before I I never think
twice about covering my drink let me
tell you something I'm 200 pounds
somebody takes my butt hey you deserve
it dude
after I wake up I can make him a gold
medal and put it over his neck
you earned that pleasure home my friend
I don't have to turn me around like dead
wait I'm pretty heavy bro is that what
you think I live for
[ __ ] he deadlifts me
like a power and control thing right oh
yeah for the same reason why like we see
a lot of assaults happening up there
like it seems to be a big person who
just [ __ ] with somebody smaller than
them because they can yeah right and
like at this point our society is in
tune to know that that shit's wrong and
especially like at this point for men to
be taking advantage of women like that's
just wrong oh I mean not because and
like that's a part of our society our
culture today our generation it's like
we we we're not down with that [ __ ] I
mean you want to talk about you know
those type of issues look at Iran right
now all right bro dude what was when I
man I feel kind of bad because
you know there are things that I really
want to talk about on this podcast but
there's so many things that kind of like
it's hard for me to read about this
stuff because it [ __ ] with my head so
much yeah it really keeps me up at night
and you know
kind of reading about this from a
cursory sense like I didn't read too
much about it but it's that woman who
got
[ __ ] bludgeoned to death yeah by the
morality police because she was you know
indecently whatever exposing herself by
whatever Iranian law of like whatever
this morality place or with the morale
that they uphold but she got [ __ ]
bludgeoned to death could you [ __ ]
imagine I mean that's Third World level
right there man the [ __ ] life is
cheap out there especially if you're a
woman because she was wearing actually
job wrong or something right well yeah
yeah they're saying that they don't want
to wear it you know and basically that's
what the protests are with women kind of
rebelling by taking it off well
apparently he saw originally it was like
she was wearing it wrong according to
the morality morality police and the
protest now are just like [ __ ] it then
yeah you know [ __ ] you we're not wearing
this if you're gonna kill me anyways
[ __ ] would I wear this [ __ ] right yeah
like and like
it's [ __ ] up because out there like
misogyny is so [ __ ] hardcore you know
and look I you can call it an
in a sense like an honor killing and you
guys know what honor killings are
like it's it's tied to the religion yeah
like a lot of uh you know you know in a
lot of Muslim countries well let's
purpose that by saying it's extremists
it's extremist yeah it's you know yeah
extreme extremist Muslims let's say you
renounce your faith and you become
another religion let's say you're
wearing a hijab wrong let's say you're
not following this or that wrong
whatever happens like your family
usually is [ __ ] up but the family
members like the father or brother were
killed you know their own family member
members their sister or their daughter
because they lost their virginity right
they're not wearing their or following
the Theocratic laws right you know
and and
I
met a guy who went through something
like this in Iraq
um there's this guy I met
so funny like he learned English from
watching friends
just like the BTS member friends is that
influential and I don't care what
anybody says a funny ass show right but
you watch Friends
um and that's how we learn to speak
English and then um
uh he invited us to his house
to meet his family and all these things
you know and uh
his dad has three wives
went to his house there's three wives
and I guess he has like nine plus
children
and his dad would speak the son we know
would translate for us he's like he'd
straight up too soon I was like do you
think it's weird
what that I have three wives what do you
think I'm like I don't know
you can handle it a lot of headaches
yeah and then like he his dad told us
this joke where like
um he said you know before the the war
um the women would always walk
uh five feet behind the men the men
would walk in front you know how do they
hold their hands they don't there's no
touching yeah dude public PDA is not a
thing bro and then he said
but after the war when the Americans
came here the women now walk five feet
ahead of the men
they're like really why and he says
so they can check for landmines
oh my God oh my God get the [ __ ] out of
here dude are you for reals right now I
mean it was a joke he was telling us a
joke
you're just quiet yeah because I'm
kidding halfway
so we we were talking to the dude we
originally met the guy who learned
English to friends and just getting to
know him
and he told me told us like
he had a girlfriend
you know
but when the family her family found out
that they were dating
like they were [ __ ] you know
and I think when the family found out
that she had lost her virginity
hey they beat the [ __ ] out of him he
told us he told me about how he was in
the hospital
bought them up so bad you know and to a
degree I can understand that
part but the other half is like what
happened to your girlfriend
he was instantly like I could see that
she was honor killed honor killed yeah
there was a story out in the UK or
something like this happened it was uh
father found out that the daughter was
having relations with somebody I don't
know if that person was Muslim or not
but either way
having a relationship outside of
marriage
um yeah he [ __ ] honored killed his
daughter in the UK and uh in Europe you
guys can look that up I think we did a
JK news on it and it was like in his
mind he goes I had to this is a part of
my religion you know and in order to
save her he had the [ __ ] honor killer
yeah I think I remember actually reading
about that Jesus man that's it's almost
like if if he hadn't done that then his
entire family would be Dishonored right
right you know it's just in their
society so [ __ ] backwards ass [ __ ]
man but you know it that's that's daily
life those are the rules out there
especially in a place like a third world
country where yeah extreme they'll cut
your hand off for theft right and this
is what I was saying too and I remember
I just read this comment that was just
so obnoxious it was like I said
um so I was alluding to the fact that I
find it very odd for people who haven't
traveled outside of this country right
and I'm talking about from you know a
lot of Christian people who have to do
missionary trips we get to see some
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
um because America has become the worst
country to live in this world and I'm
like I don't think you know how it is to
live in other countries you just read an
article about a girl who got bludgeoned
to death because she wore a hijabra
right we just we and this was during the
time we were mentioning it uh about
during the the war you know Ukraine and
Russian as this is happening people are
in Twitter are like it sucks to be an
American because it's the worst country
to live in and then somebody wrote the
comment is like well you can't you can't
compare trauma to trauma yes I can yeah
in this case I can for you to talk about
this country being the most horrific
place to live in blows my mind when you
have the knowledge of the internet and
you could read all this stuff and you're
retweeting the stuff about how terrible
this is and then you didn't get your
Starbucks order right and then like the
disrespect I faced today like let's not
get it twisted yes the things that are
happening here can be horrific and it's
unbearable but I agree we live in a
[ __ ] very pretty privilege first
world country you know this it's not
this [ __ ] place where you have to
work the life is cheap and you gotta
worry about honor killings and you know
I mean like that's nothing like poor
people have the internet here you know
yeah right if they find it somehow you
know like the way that's why the
homeless Boost Mobile yeah that's why
the homeless people go to the library to
masturbate there because they watch porn
you know [ __ ] uh what's it called
um Jeffrey Dahmer this full uh did
something decent exposure he was jacking
off showing his dick to people that fool
had to pay a 50 fine back in the day oh
my God that flashes dick around kids are
like 50 bucks yeah we're Square
all right I'm gonna do it again you know
I mean listen like you know to go back
to the first topic that we're talking
about just to reiterate man like we're
I'm gonna post this girl's GoFundMe for
her father's like funeral proceedings
like I'm so curious to see like I wonder
how people feel about this and I do want
people to understand like listen I'm
never siding with people who are thieves
right but I do value human life on both
sides that girl's a piece of [ __ ] and
that girl she either needs to be in jail
for [ __ ] life or stabbing somebody to
death over a [ __ ] wig piece and then
also too I didn't mention that she did a
[ __ ] IG live after this yeah that's
that's the most terrible thing about it
man it's just like the AMA Reddit guy
these two people to me like bothers me
it bothers me that's that's kind of like
where it just [ __ ] mind-blowingly
stupid is that we live in this world of
you know this instant gratification
through a screen and like you're always
on right whether you're broadcasting on
Instagram or Tick Tock whatever and some
of these people who are obviously kind
of [ __ ] up in the head that doesn't
change for them their heinous actions
still are broadcasted on there because
that's just what life is it's just like
putting evidence into the crime they
don't think about it like that though
they just think about it from a
standpoint oh this just happened so like
yeah exactly
don't [ __ ] with me yeah [ __ ] but
it's like dude you're right stupid [ __ ]
made contact man you have any idea like
how like this is a guy who was an
immigrant right comes to this country
opens up his own business and to [ __ ]
get stabbed to death by this piece of
[ __ ] over a [ __ ] wig dude blows my
mind I know man I know but
it blows my [ __ ] mind I couldn't
imagine if somebody that's my father I
know that's what I was telling Ed like
earlier I was like dude I can't even
imagine what I would do if that was my
because like while I was watching the
clip of of kind of the altercation that
happened before the stabbing I was just
seeing my dad yeah and I was like my
blood started to [ __ ] boil inside I'm
not gonna lie when I see something like
that what I'm thinking my initial
thinking is yellow yeah exactly I I have
murderous intent well that's part of the
a lot of the opposition we had from the
last podcast we did yeah it's because
people do see that and it does make
their blood boil yeah and it does call
it gives them a conviction to do
something like to take up action yeah
but like I'll reiterate this again
like is it for the sake of humanity or
really you just want revenge exactly are
you in acting in fear or are you trying
to make this place you know a better
place to live in because it's not like I
don't feel that too like I I you know
yeah I think like it's easy for me to
say I wish I could if that happened to
my father I would find that girl and I
would [ __ ] stab her to death bro
yeah feeling it is one thing I'm saying
I felt that now would I actually act on
it as a as a grown mature man no yeah I
wouldn't right or or I would have to to
like use every [ __ ] ounce of
restraint in my body to prevent myself
from doing it but I would think of the
repercussions right that's the core word
you think about it yeah yeah you think
about it yeah so much of the [ __ ]
that we see is because people aren't
thinking about it and I want to be
better than that you know and here's the
hard part too and I think that I had an
issue with people celebrating the like
death yeah I can't celebrate with you on
that type of stuff I can't celebrate the
fact that this kid got stabbed and he's
paralyzed I'm not doing any of that [ __ ]
I'm looking at the tragedy I got
disturbed by people cheering this person
on like he's a [ __ ] hero yeah that's
my problem yeah right we're not here
talking hypotheticals either what
Shoulda Woulda could have happened we're
talking about what happened yeah what
actually happened what happened you know
because a lot of the comments I read too
well what if but you know this could
have it's like no but that's not what
happened we don't need to talk about the
what ifs just look at yeah how it it
there's video evidence yeah there's not
it's not even described you could watch
what happens I know and you know I know
it's a weird thing it's like oh and the
people will twist your words constantly
it doesn't really matter they go so
you're saying you would be why you
mentioning you know Bart getting stabbed
to death and dying I was like I'm
talking about your logic like things
have to be dealt with blood right and so
despite all the stuff the transformation
this man has changed he's become all the
good that he has done in his community
like his Redemption Arc or whatever the
[ __ ] it is by your [ __ ] logic because
he was this Affiliated gay member
whoever he hung out with was a heat when
he dies you should all celebrate and say
he deserved his death
as of its past because of his past and
we're seeing that as a problem now in
our social lives with cancer culture
yeah you know and now it's it's stepping
up to a point where we're actually
seeing people being killed in their the
people celebrating it yeah [ __ ] why
and so when I cry over the fact that
where my my brother's dead body are you
guys going to say to me well look at you
defending this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
cousin you know for you know this guy
did this this guy said that so he does
like that but that's not what happened
today but the thing is it's easy to pass
judgment when you're doing it on the
other side of a screen and it doesn't
involve anybody you know yeah you know
what I mean it's so easy to do but it's
like yeah well imagine you in your shoes
having to pay for your mistakes that you
made when you were younger when you were
stupid and you're not that person
anymore but somehow some way it comes to
light today you got to pay for it now
yeah you got to pay for it either
through getting canceled and or getting
you know assaulted or you know God
forbid even getting killed for it
then then what yeah right then then your
your uh reaction to it and your thoughts
on it completely changed like well but
but there's a lot of butts now yeah your
butts would be more than that for this
though I want to tell people man there's
a and my point being is that it's not as
easy as everybody's making it sound
right I'm talking about the Spectrum and
how complicated this stuff is these
issues are never black and white there's
this weird gray metal in between right
where I have to believe in like for me
and my maybe my sanity and I could be
wrong in this case and this is probably
what people hate about me it's like I I
want to believe in the good of people
and humanity and the ability to change
right I don't think it's my place or to
take somebody's life away right and it's
hard because I've been in those
situations where yeah if I had to if
somebody came into this room right now
barging in and I had my gun and I'm
thinking like this guy's trying to rob
us and kill us yeah I'd probably be in
that shoes I'd probably kill that guy
right because I'm going to value my life
and my friend's life first so yeah I
might even in this case it might seem a
little hypocritical but I guess my point
is like
I number one I didn't like people
celebrating that kid as a [ __ ] hero
right and I value my life over products
it's mainly the points that I was saying
right and these situations are not black
and white This is complicated it's
nuanced it's loaded man it's loaded with
a lot of [ __ ] I mean some people might
be able to relate more based on personal
experience and some people are just
looking at it on very surface level and
again they're passing judgment behind
the screen behind the keyboard is what I
call vicarious PTSD there you go the
fact that you you saw a video clip it
didn't happen to you but you empathize
very hard because that person looks like
you yeah it's and it's fine to have
empathy it's completely fine to have
empathy but the moment you cross that
line into passing judgment yeah of being
like this person is an absolute whatever
because of this
that's where I think you're alluding to
the fact that it can be gray area yeah
right like I said I just felt really
sickened I think I wouldn't have had
such a a hard stance on this if it
wasn't for that [ __ ] AMA Reddit yeah
that's the [ __ ] that [ __ ] with me hard
yeah yeah
if that [ __ ] just happened and I said
like damn that's [ __ ] up situation you
know the law will deal with it kind of
thing then you see this guy's Tire yeah
there's a whole Mo about it and like
it's as if like he was so glad that his
security camera actually caught the fact
that he stabbed somebody to death that
he can post it a lot about it because he
posted on Instagram he posted on Reddit
I mean come on it was Cloud chasing man
yeah he was clout chasing through
killing somebody and justifying it and
then people see us being upset with that
and think that we're defending the
thieves like that's not what we're
talking about yeah it's a behavior
afterwards yeah you protected your life
great but that's all fine and good now
why do you have to [ __ ] go and do all
this other [ __ ] about it right that
makes it seem like you you enjoyed it
yeah you kind of enjoyed it
it's a [ __ ] model yeah man well I'm
curious to see what you guys say in the
comments once again uh the GoFundMe is
going to be in this description box uh
below please donate if you can to um
this tragedy that happened I'm curious
to see what you guys think about this um
like I said I'm I'm all over the place
let's let's predict the comments I don't
know I know what the comments are David
you're a hypocrite because the last one
you said yeah well you know it's cool
man suck my dick
uh secret society fall line is coming
out man
um you guys see on my Instagram stories
I'm posting of what we did man this
[ __ ] this fall drop is going to be
insane man like we're like I said like
this isn't a merch Brand This is a
[ __ ] full-on clothing line man and
we're we're after all these big heads
the ones that [ __ ] charge you 300
bucks for a hoodie or whatever we do
what they do 10 times [ __ ] better and
a way better cost than you get this same
or if not better quality I'm dead
serious about this [ __ ] man like this is
like one of our biggest passion products
that we kept for what five six years now
yeah yeah I mean at some points it would
have made more sense to just call it
quits you know yeah but kept kept going
at it survived endured now now we're
throwing now we're thriving you know
before we end this we're gonna we're
gonna show you guys what's up because on
the video side if you get to see this
man now mind you guys these are just the
samples these aren't the finished
production pieces here but this is our
brand new color uh this is the model
colors our first long sleeve tee this is
a custom knit fabric Rick so yeah we
custom made this very soft hand feel we
got the uh rubber vinyl cut out right
here right don't you just want to keep
touching it oh my God right yo that's so
pleasant right [ __ ] my fingers
it's so pleasant though oh [ __ ] yeah so
yeah it's the first time we're doing
like a cut out of the logo here like
this but more than that this this
[ __ ] rubber vinyl is just so pleasant
to look at and to touch and again first
long sleeve tee we got the secondary hit
right here on the back with the numbers
um yeah this [ __ ] is beautiful dude yeah
it's it's it's a it's a work of beauty
right here and I'm not even just saying
that crew neck okay it is the crew neck
here
um and for those of y'all listening just
trust me okay just trust me it feels
nice all right same uh same kind of
thing yeah very soft hand feel
um heavy weight yeah oversized nice if I
was wearing this I'd be just touching my
chest yeah exactly uh we got the side
slip pockets on this that you guys are
familiar with from the Vintage shoes
collection just the crew neck and then
same thing uh with the number Hits on
the back and we're keeping it simple
this time where we're just running One
Design
um where yeah it's it's just the SS logo
on the front and then the numbers on the
back for the tops dude the the quality
the feel of this is amazing and look I'm
not [ __ ] on anybody's stuff who put
their stuff out there like listen we
different yeah yeah look like look we we
just keep trying to elevate with each
new collection that we put out there
because you know we've had the Good
Fortune especially from you guys thank
you guys for your support we're real
yeah we've been growing and we've been
doing relatively well considering where
we were less than a year ago right even
a year ago I mean [ __ ] you you guys
gotta understand we literally
resurrected this [ __ ] from the dead less
than a year ago yeah we re launched kind
of relaunched I look at it as a restart
almost starting from scratch November of
last year a pandemic butt [ __ ] us yeah
and so it hasn't it hasn't even been a
year since we came back although it's
I'm not gonna lie I feel like 10 years
for me this in this time but yeah we
just keep trying to step it up with each
new collection that we drop and look
even our production guy was like hey man
you gotta raise your prices like you you
guys are crazy selling this at the
prices you guys are selling it at he's
like bro these are easily two three
hundred dollar hoodies and and like
crewnecks like what are you guys doing
and look we we try to give you value
across the board that's that's what
we're always going to try to do and look
there are going to be times where we're
gonna have to raise our price points
because you guys know costs are going up
across the board inflation all that [ __ ]
as much as possible right right but
we're trying to still keep it very
competitive relative to the mark market
and the type of quality you would get
out there for a price that's far like
two three times four times our cost and
we're we're really trying to compete
with that so and this is not lip service
too like if you guys are into fashion
and you've had like you know I I know
people who Rock very very expensive
Brands and those people who have bought
our [ __ ] they go like yo this is like
similar if not better [ __ ] the the best
validation that we can get is when we
get messages and emails like you know I
would never spend x amount on a t or a
hoodie or whatever but after getting
your guys's stuff
I see it's worth every single dollar
yeah and that's you know that's the
point too right it's it you're not just
it's hard to describe as like how I
don't know how many times you guys have
ever bought [ __ ] just because of the
name of the clout that you got from it
but you got a [ __ ] [ __ ] product and
that happens so much in this fashion
industry yeah it happens all the time
and listen like I I've definitely been
that you know little hypebeast [ __ ]
that bought a couple of pieces and then
I remember like my my biggest moment
that I had was when I went to Japan and
I went to like in the Fashion District I
went to a specific streetwear brand and
the original tags from the blanks that
they got wasn't taken off on it yeah and
it was the shittiest blank ever and the
shirt was a hundred and forty dollars
yeah and I was willing to buy that
because I wanted the hype and then when
I saw this I was like hold on a second
this shirt cost a dollar at a flea
market and they slapped slapped on their
logo and they were charging 140 bucks
for it and I was willing to buy it and
exactly they do it because they can
because there's thousands tens of
thousands of people like you who would
gladly buy that [ __ ] because of the hype
surrounding it and look man I hope one
day we can get to a point where we are a
recognized you know name household name
from a brand standpoint but more than
that like our our core thing is always
trying to pay attention to the details
and just offer Great Value across them I
just want people to walk out and then
just have somebody stop them and be like
where'd you get that sweater yeah and
and again when we hear about stuff like
that it's the yo before we go I'll tell
you a quick story you know Megan Megan
King right she told me his story
recently about her meeting and aunt and
um a Nuna right she's like an older
sister to me because of a secret society
hat and it turns out like one of them
was wearing the hats like hey that's my
friend's brand it's like wait you know
so and so and it all connected them and
I was like that's so [ __ ] tight I was
like why didn't my aunt or my Nina tell
me about this [ __ ] yeah why are you the
only one telling me about this that's
amazing man that's you know when I hear
stuff like that that's another thing
that's really important to the brand
aspect effect from like Community
creating Community through it I always
you know wanted the idea of like you
know like in Fight Club where kind of
the marks on their faces is is the
um unspoken understanding that they're a
part of this this club right this this
is the the the burn Market yeah yeah
exactly you can't listen I can't wait
till this [ __ ] is gonna be like
I'm gonna manifest it I've been reading
about all these [ __ ] talking
about this [ __ ] I can't wait till this
is like in everybody's [ __ ] closet
yeah yeah I mean we we uh redesigned the
sweats too a little more modern
contemporary and this is our turquoise I
[ __ ] love this color dude yeah this
is amazing color so these are two of our
newer colors uh that we're gonna have
five colors for this set in total along
with two new pants and I believe four
new sweaters knit sweaters uh we're
gonna have new we got a bunch of [ __ ]
if you guys [ __ ] loved our our first
launch with our crop pants yeah the
chico pants the chico pants version 2.0
so version 2.0 is coming out in two
colorways uh we kind of
um tapered it a little bit more so
that's kind of what we're going for with
this whole collection is we just want a
little bit more contemporary tapered
look now a lot of the uh tops are
oversized but I think there's this
common misconception let's clear that up
too when when people hear oversized they
just think like a triple XL fit no
that's not what it means the length of
this like like for example yeah it can
fit right but maybe it's baggier here or
maybe it's baggier in the Torso and the
length is like so that can also be an
oversized fit but when people I think
who don't really know too much about
like fashion and these terms they hear
oversized they just think oh it's going
to fit like a double XL on me no no no
no no no you could fit your normal size
but maybe it's just a little baggier fit
more boxier fit you know so you'll see
this a lot with a lot of Brands where
you know I've definitely bought a few
shirts where they're like oh this is an
oversized tee and it's literally just a
larger size Miss name right and I'm like
this is not an oversized tee the cut
isn't made to be oversized exactly the
sleeve length on the shirt is wrong the
way that it fits down in the way that it
drapes on your body is not oversized
it's just a bigger size t-shirt right
there is a huge difference yeah and so
this is kind of like the stuff that
that's why I say like um I didn't want
to do merch because I wanted to do
stuff like this right because
selling merch is a lot easier than
building a clothing line for sure it's
it's and we've definitely taking up this
task that's a lot more difficult but
we're still going at it and you know our
numbers are growing so definitely people
are seeing something that um that we've
been trying this message that we're
trying to get across and somehow it's
[ __ ] working and I think what it is
is that when people receive the products
they know what's up yeah you can't
either way it can't be denied when you
receive it you understand what's up yeah
and and and look again that's that's
what we're trying to hit we're trying to
hit all those points right of just like
quality product
um relatively affordable prices you know
looks dope feels dope all of that and
luckily yeah people have recognized that
when they when they get the stuff and
again we're just trying to keep building
on that idea with each new collection
and at some point I mean there's so many
things that you know we want to do with
the brand and it's just like explore
other things within it
but we're getting there little by little
you know little by little so be excited
for the Fall Line it's gonna drop uh we
got accessories now we got socks that
are coming out [ __ ] walking yeah
we're Rock rocking it right here so
we're gonna have not many numbers oh
yeah put my feet down we're gonna have
the uh white one and the black one just
classic SS logo and the feel of these
socks are so nice too it's so soft and
look guys I don't just say this [ __ ]
because I'm part of the brand all right
like all right let me feel this oh [ __ ]
it's it's comfortable it's not because
look I'm always thinking about it from a
standpoint of like what if I was the one
buying this I was the one spending money
on this how would I feel about it and
from that standpoint I always feel like
we're delivering on on what we're
talking about and what we're promising
and yeah we're super excited about this
fall winter collection coming up it's
today is what October 7th so we're
aiming towards hopefully by the end of
this month or early November around the
same time that the last fall winter so
it's like kind of now our full circle
moment like that full year right and you
gotta understand too when you talk about
a small ass team yeah people
people are all right bro this is not
easy a trick and our designer well we
got we have three or four Partners in
total and then the warehouse team right
so that's really about it yeah so it's
we don't have a big team here guys yeah
it's it's it's a big lofty dream man and
it's really hard to kind of like how do
we offer something that people don't
have right um and I think that's the
difficult part about building a brand
um is innovation is always providing
something that people didn't know that
they needed and this is what I think uh
secret society is trying to fill we're
trying to fill that hole right now yeah
it's a really interesting space like if
if anybody [ __ ] with that brand John
Elliott right I mean there their [ __ ] is
pricey and I like their [ __ ] I just
can't super expensive I saw one of their
like shorts that I wanted the cop right
damn that's just it was this floor plan
like sublimated uh like Jersey Shore
yeah that's time get that [ __ ] 200 bucks
I was like hey man
yeah that's gonna hurt that's good for
basketball yeah
yeah but but you know kind of going back
to just real quick about the costing too
is that you guys gotta understand like a
good chunk of our stuff is domestic
production and so costs here are much
much higher than overseas production
and for the most part we want to try to
keep things here uh and do it
domestically here in LA to support small
businesses as well we're not fast
fashion either so yeah I think what
people have to understand too it's like
I don't [ __ ] hate fast food there are
times where I get fast fashion [ __ ] all
the time it serves a purpose but I
understand that I got three watches on
that [ __ ] and then after that that [ __ ]
is going to look different yeah and it's
going to feel different and I understand
that there's a reason why I'm paying for
20 15 shorts because I know for a fact
that it's not going to fit that great I
know for a fact that it's not going to
wash well it's not going to keep well
and it's going to be [ __ ] and I
understand that [ __ ] I that's why I pay
for it but
um I get what I pay for yeah right yeah
every secret society piece I still have
now and I and I'm hoping that the
feeling that people have when they get
our stuff is they got more than what
they paid for yes that's that's what I
really want them to feel and it feels
like they're half people there have been
people who have felt that way and that's
again validation right you just feel
like they get it they understand what
we're trying to do and it feels amazing
to to know that we're we're succeeding
in what we're trying to do it's hard
yeah clothing line y'all but uh you guys
have been supporting us and kind of kept
us alive so really really appreciate
especially with the uh the genius brain
collab like I said I am that was let me
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
amazing like I it's it's very seldom
that you ever get to see like a cad
version of a shirt and then the thing in
person looks ten times better than it
did in this [ __ ] photo and this is
what this is like this [ __ ] came out so
amazing so you have to understand that
when we decided to pull the stuff that
we got because it didn't work out well
was because it didn't come up to our
standards and quality I said in the
stories like people were messaging me
like just send it out we're just there
to support you it doesn't matter because
I cannot say no [ __ ] absolutely not
you spent good money on this [ __ ] you're
gonna get what you paid exactly 100 100
yeah uh just because you know this is
like a capsule collection item that's a
collaboration piece with like genius
brain secret society it doesn't mean
that we're gonna skimp on it and just do
whatever is easy no no no it's still the
part of the brand it still exists in
that world it's our integrity exactly
exactly so you got to make sure that
again when you guys get this we want you
to feel the same way of [ __ ] I'm getting
more than I paid for like I really love
every dollar that I spent on this this
[ __ ] makes me so proud to be Korean yeah
well I feel like this design really
transcended just the Korean [ __ ] because
we had a lot of non-korean people who I
mean look at it how could you say it's
not dope like if you saw that from
across the room you'd look at it would
catch your attention for damn sure dude
the the [ __ ] raised the the raised
design specifically this I think that's
the thing that I love the most yeah for
sure like that texture thing yeah I know
yeah it gives kind of like the the brain
you know feeling right like the Vintage
color palette for the the panchang
design which you don't see a lot of
people do the uh the modern version
where it's super bright yeah but like
this is a part of that Temple history
the color palette is very important you
have no [ __ ] idea how hard it was for
this guy to get this color right it was
so yeah we had to do a lot of trial and
error process with it because it wasn't
easy especially because there's so many
colors so many fine lines and there's
multiple layers to it so yo shout out to
the homie who did by the way we we work
with a very specific guy that does all
of our stuff yeah yo shout out to this
guy because who else would have [ __ ]
done this right right it's a difficult
last project yeah
um but I mean [ __ ] look at it it was
worth it the investment that we put into
it that [ __ ] turned out great so
um thank you guys for for waiting thank
you guys for your patience and your
understanding but yeah we just want to
make sure you guys have the best version
possible of what we had in mind and yeah
that's why we couldn't send out the yeah
our first batch of that stuff so anyways
guys genius brain every Sunday's at 12
p.m of course we had to do a little
infomercial at the end
for
5.99.
you're not gonna pay 199 not even 189
not 179 not 169. not 149 not even 99 not
10 days later yeah just call 900
555555 I called that number and I got
that Ron Paul peel Machine by the way
one of the best things I ever got before
bro had it for [ __ ] like 10 years
made the best chicken got me so much
[ __ ] which is just really one girl who
was a little overweight and she loved me
for it uh genius brain every Sundays at
12 p.m you could catch Ed at Ed Too
secret society
s-e-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y make sure you guys
check us out follow the Instagram wait
for these updates when the fall line
drop apps [ __ ] goes out [ __ ] fast uh
like I said super hyped for the [ __ ] I
cannot wait to see you guys rock this
[ __ ] make sure that when you get the
stuff post your [ __ ] secret fit tag
me text tags please tag us and then you
can follow Ed at the one at Park VP and
you can see him on the genius brain
podcast uh stay blessed love you guys
make sure that you guys talk in the
comments whether it's on the podcast
side or the videos I want to hear your
opinions about these situations love you
all very much I [ __ ] love you
yeah bye [ __ ] peace